CALLS DERELICTION OF DUTY.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISING TO
TURN THE NATION'S GRIEF INTO
ACTION WHEN IT COMES TO GUNS AND
HE'S CONTINUING TO CHAMPION THE
IDEA OF ARMING TEACHERS AND
FACULTY OR SOME TRAINED
PERSONNEL INSIDE SCHOOLS.
HE SAYS BUMP STOCKS ARE "GONE."
NO MATTER WHAT CONGRESS DOES AND
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT MORE LATITUDE TO
TAKE GUNS AWAY FROM HIGH-RISK
PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED TO THE
NATION'S GOVERNORS TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SAID HE WOULD
HAVE GONE INTO THAT SCHOOL AND
GONE AFTER THE FLORIDA SHOOTER,
WEAPON OR NOT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WANTS
TO CHANGE SOME OF THE LAWS
REGARDING GUN OWNERSHIP IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING THE NATION'S
SCHOOLS, THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES
THE CHEAPEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DO IT IS TO FIGHT FIRE
WITH FIRE.
IN HIS THIRD MAJOR LISTENING
SESSION, PRESIDENT TRUMP MET
WITH MOST OF THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY, INSISTING THE BEST WAY TO
DETER SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IS TO LET
KILLERS KNOW THEY WON'T MAKE IT
OUT ALIVE.
>> THE BAD GUY HAS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A BIG PRICE TO PAY
WHEN THEY MESS AROUND WITH OUR
STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE TO KNOW.
THEY WALK IN.
THEY ARE PROBABLY GOING TO END
UP DEAD AND IF THEY KNOW THEY
ARE GOING TO END UP DEAD, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO VET SCHOOL.
>> ON HIS PROPOSAL TO TRAIN AND
ARM QUALIFIED MEMBERS OF FACULTY
AND STAFF, PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT
PUSHBACK FROM JAY INSLEE.
>> I HAVE LISTENED TO
FIRST GRADE TEACHERS WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE PISTOL PACKING
TEACHERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO TRAIN
TEACHERS AS LAW-ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
WE NEED A LITTLE LESS TWEETING,
MORE LISTENING.
LET'S TAKE IT OFF THE TABLE AND
MOVE FORWARD.
>> NOT JUST DEMOCRATS WILL POST
THE IDEA.
FLORIDA'S REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT, STAUNCH
SUPPORTER OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
SAYS EDUCATORS SHOULD EDUCATE.
PROTECTING SCHOOLS AS A JOB HE
WANTS LAW-ENFORCEMENT TO TAKE
ON.
>> I'M NOT WAITING FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST
$500 MILLION, SIGNIFICANT
LAW-ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE AT
EVERY SCHOOL IN OUR STATE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE WOULDN'T
WEIGH IN ON CALLS FOR
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S GOT
ISRAEL TO STEP DOWN OR BE
INVESTIGATED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LASHED OUT AT
DEPUTY SCOT PETERSON AND
POSSIBLY OTHERS FOR NOT RUSHING
YOU IN SCHOOL TO TAKE ON THE
SHOOTER, SAYING HE WOULD HAVE
DONE IT DIFFERENTLY.
>> THERE WEREN'T EXACTLY MEDAL
OF HONOR WINNERS, THE WAY THEY
PERFORMED WAS FRANKLY
DISGUSTING.
I REALLY BELIEVE YOU DON'T KNOW
UNTIL YOU TEST IT.
I REALLY BELIEVE I WOULD RUN
INCOME EVEN IF I DIDN'T HAVE A
WEAPON.
I THINK MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM WOULD'VE DONE THAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED IF
CONGRESS DOESN'T ACT SOON TO BAN
SO-CALLED BUMP STOCKS USED BY
THE SHOOTER IN THE LAS VEGAS
MASSACRE, HE WILL DO IT HIMSELF.
WHILE HE HASN'T MENTIONED THE
MINIMUM WAGE FOR BUYING A RIFLE,
HE SUPPORTS THE CONCEPT AND SAYS
HE IS PREPARED TO GO TOE-TO-TOE
WITH THE NRA.
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE NRA.
HALF OF YOU ARE SO AFRAID OF THE
NRA.
THERE'S NOTHING TO BE AFRAID OF.
IF THEY ARE NOT WITH YOU, WE
HAVE TO FIGHT THEM EVERY ONCE IN
A WHILE.
THAT'S OKAY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP REVEALED HE
HAD LUNCH YESTERDAY WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE NRA, WAYNE
LaPIERRE AND CHRIS COX.
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE NRA TOLD
FOX NEWS A FEW MINUTES AGO THE
GLUE LEADERSHIP HAS NOT DROPPED
ITS OPPOSITION TO RAISING THE
MINIMUM WAGE TO BUY A RIFLE.
>> Bret: BREAKING NEWS, JUST
CONFIRMED, ABOUT HOPE HICKS.
>> WE LEARNED A LITTLE WHILE AGO
AND THEN ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S INNER CIRCLE, HOPE
HICKS, WILL BE PAYING A VISIT TO
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
SHE IS THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR.
SHE WAS THE SPOKESPERSON AND
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR THROUGH
THE CAMPAIGN.
SHE WILL BE VISITING THE HOUSE